the objects and artifacts that Define a
culture for many Native Americans those
items are no longer in their possession
instead they're held by museums
universities and other institutions and
while efforts continue to try to return
them to tribal Nations something else
that was taken away decades ago can
never fully be restored
and it was just always hanging in
essentially our living room for Brandy
Tyree this isn't just a Buckskin dress
in a perfect world every time somebody
sees and hears about Emma I hope they
think about how important is that we are
inclusive and that people get to be who
they are it's an artifact made in 1903
by her great-grandmother Emma sansaver
which was donated to the University of
Montana by tyree's mother
sand saver was a Native American student
at the Fort Shaw Indian boarding school
one of more than 400 government-operated
boarding schools that Force native
children to assimilate by stripping them
of their language and culture they had
to be white at all times except when it
was convenient I think the school
decided that a way to get publicity for
how awesome these schools were that they
would take these young women around to
play basketball they let them design and
make their own native dresses that they
could wear at halftime how confusing was
it you were making a dress so you could
be yourself at halftime
but all the other times you had to be
was somebody else's definition of white
a culture that wasn't yours they played
so well that they were invited to the
Louisiana state purchase exposition of
1904 better known as the St Louis
World's Fair sandsaver and her teammates
defeated every opponent and were coined
champions of the world so I found out
that it was intact and donated to the
school and so it was on display there
and I was kind of Blown Away at that
point teacher Cody Munson a first
generation descendant of the Salish
tribe among others uses what has become
known as Emma's dress as a teaching tool
it's something that we can visualize and
and see now at the University of Montana
the school's anthropology department
preserves the artifact to a certain
extent native students kind of have a
sense of Pride that kind of comes along
with with the story of the fort Shaw
team and Emma's dress and you know
bringing some of that reality back to
light shows that they have a little more
story than than people have told
previously students Raymond Combs and
mcalen running Fisher support the
efforts to preserve the dress
I just introduced myself in the
Blackfoot language my Indian name was
given to me by my grand my grandpa and
it means shining eyes woman that has
been passed down Generations so when I
do introduce myself I do say it proudly
running Fisher says her grandparents and
great-grandparents were forced to attend
boarding schools which makes her work
here even more meaningful
there are protocols with how you enter
and exit and introduce artifacts into
the room that they're being kept yeah so
for everyone it's different every tribe
is uniquely different when I go in there
I have to protect myself so I smudge
myself with sage and put that protection
with dealing with these objects you know
coming in there with the right mind the
right heart being respectful it's really
important to acknowledge that these
objects are important you know talking
to them and making sure you know like
I'm I'm here to take care of you and I'm
going to bring you home because you're
going to be at rest eventually this
brings up the difficult conversation
around repatriation recent reporting
found that the remains and funerary
objects of more than a hundred ten
thousand Native American native Hawaiian
and Alaskan natives ancestors are still
being held by museums universities and
federal agencies that's despite a 1990
federal law calling for the items to be
returned to descendants or tribal
Nations I maintain that's maybe 20 of
what has actually been stolen they're
everywhere they're in private
collections they're in universities
they're in museums and half the time
they're not even displayed so what are
you doing with those remains it it
approaches the macabre
many of these institutions still hold in
their possession
pieces of history that don't belong to
them yeah I mean my first thought is and
it might be naive it's just that it's
just crazy to think that we do that like
why
um I mean Heck if I borrow a friend's
sweater I want to make sure they get it
back right away right so why do people
need to keep something that's not theirs
I think all these artifacts they need to
go back to where they belong and where
they're honored and cherished and people
can learn the history about them one
thing I'm most proud of my parents
especially my mom she's worked so hard
for this is that this is a collaboration
for all of us to learn
and it feels like we would have Emma's
permission
University of Montana currently holds 67
Native American artifacts 42 have been
made available for return while 25 have
not the university says it will continue
to partner closely with tribal historic
preservation officers and the tribal
cultural heritage board to ensure
repatriation the sacred artifacts are
stored protectively and can only be seen
by those given official permission as we
were with Emma's dress which is building
a bridge between the past and the future
when children come and see it what do
you hope they take away
I hope it makes them curious
to dive into the Curiosity of what
they're learning in school and how much
more there is to learn and different
places to learn also just when they come
visit here they're on a college campus
so I hope that inspires them to dream
their big dreams but yeah just to be
curious and to question history
question history you know part of the
challenge of returning some of these
objects is the fact that there is no
distinct tribal affiliation they're
still trying to figure out which tribes
own these pieces of history and so the
University of Montana has been working
to you know establish relationships
other entities across the country same
situation it's good that they're having
the conversations I think we've said
that before you hope that they can find
who those belong to and should start
returning and just to see the dress in
person right not just see a picture of
it not just hear about it but just it's
a display yeah that's important too yeah